well today's vet segment is all about
pets and heat and the measures
we need to take to keep them all safe
now checking back in today with dr
jamie augustine medical director of
oasis animal hospital
in henderson thank you so much for
talking to us today thank you for having
me again
well let's get started the first
question on every dog owner's mind is
when is the safest time of day
to take our pets out for exercise
during the summer the safest time is
going to be very early in the morning
like five to seven or after the sun has
gone down behind the mountains
it gets very hot and people
think that their pads are good enough
for the
pavement but it's not i always recommend
that you check the
the ground with either your bare feet or
your palm
because they can definitely burn their
pads and you want to make sure you take
water and this doesn't apply just for
dogs
there are people who do take cats on
walks and cats paws are just as
sensitive as dogs
if not more so you have to be very
careful in the heat
and go when it's nice and cool that's a
good tip there to make sure that you put
your hand
down on the pavement and if it's too hot
obviously it's going to be too hot for
them but you mentioned that the pavement
is also as hot um what about desert
terrain is that just as bad
that's actually even worse not only is
it hot but it's rough
and i have had people say well they're
not on the concrete so let me go run
them in the desert
and then they come back and they wonder
why they can't walk
is because their pads are torn up and i
mean torn up and pads take a
very long time to heal and so you want
to be very careful where you take them
and you're not just out to the desert on
for walks
if you're taking your pet anywhere to
the veterinary hospital to the groomer
you want to be careful that they're
being careful when they walk into the
facility
and also that you've got good at
adequate air conditioning for them and
the air conditioner is reaching them
in the back of the car so they don't get
too hot in the car
yeah and those are all really good tips
especially because obviously
you know our pets really don't talk but
they do have different
um signs that they sometimes will tell
us that something is wrong so just kind
of keep a close eye on all of them
especially when you're walking them out
during the next couple of months now we
did speak to fire rescue recently who
reminded us
that if we see any type of pets outside
in a hot parked car to contact the
authorities why
is this so important to take action not
just look the other way when something
like this happens
because we know it can kill them it can
kill humans and it can kill animals and
there's
all too many stories of it happening of
beloved pets people go
they think well let me just run it in
i'm going to crack the window down and
i'm going to run in real quick
cracking the window is not enough to get
enough air flow
and those the cars in the summer
are like ovens and it doesn't take but a
few minutes to reach hot enough
to to put them into a heat exhaustion
and sometimes they don't come back from
that
so just don't do it make sure you
remember you've got a kid or a pet in
the car
and just don't leave them in the car if
you're running in even for just a minute
yeah it only takes just a couple of
minutes like you said for that can
really
make a big difference um with our pets
outside
in the heat now finally doctor let me
ask you it's all often
that we report on animal abuse and
neglect during the summer months
of people leaving their pets out in the
hot sun with no fresh water no shade
what would you like pet owners to know
about the subject
personally i'd like to see all pets
inside during the summer and if they're
going to go outside make sure they've
got adequate protection
from the sun they've got fresh water if
they're going to be outside
and live outside make sure they've got
shade make sure they've got airflow make
sure they've got
fresh clean water and then mostly pay
attention to your
pets love on them give them attention
but check on them check their water
check their
their their surroundings check their
bedding just keep an
eye on your pet like you would any
individual who can't take care of
themselves
all right dr jamie oginski thank you so
much for talking to us this afternoon
uh and those are some great tips uh that
you have for all of us i mean especially
for our little fur babies like i said
they sometimes don't talk
but there's different ways of them
telling us that hey you know it's too
hot just maybe turn up that ac in your
car
thank you so much for talking to us
we'll talk to you soon thank you so much